♪ ♪ ♪nt
à quitter la station spatiale.
Les modules russes
s'en détachent. Applaudissements
dans la salle de contrôle.
Cette vidéo satir
résume lrésume lrésume lrésume e
dans laquelle se trouventactuels
de la station.
OLIVIER HERNANDEZ, directeur,- e
géopolitique a plombé l'ambiancs
la station. On voit bien
qu'il y a des dissensions.
directeur de l'Agence spatiale
russe lui-même qui mène
l'attaque.
"Si les américains persistent,
dit-il, nous allons remettre en
question
de la station spatiale."
"Sans nous, la station ne peut
ni se déplacer, ni fonctionn
Dimtry Rogozine est un habitué
des polémiques. Il vient
d'ailleu
d'"imbécile" un astronaute
américain critique du président
NEAU, député PLC,
astronaute à la retraite- La rée
moment, le centre de contrôle
en Russie et le centre
fonctionnent bien, ensemble.
aussi hyaussi hyaussi hyaussi h,
n'annonce rien de bon.
- On pourrait éventuellement
la station sans la Russie, si la
qu'elle ne participe plus, maisi
assure maintenant l'essentie
du transport des passagers
vers la Station, croit qu'el
pourrait remplacer les russe
presqu'à pied levé.
Mais dans les faits, toute la
station est le fruit de trente
ans de pn.- Pour piloter la staa
prend des Russes, pour justement
faire les corrections
d'altitude. Mais l'énergie,
l'électricité néce
du module américain,
donc c'est interco
- En parallèle, les Européens
centre s Russes. Russes. Russes.
Moscou cesse de lancer des
un mois, on se demande si le vok
Vande Hei aura lieu comme prévu,
dans une capsule Soyouz.fait qun
qu'il est dans la station, on
arrive uu'on est
capable de le prolonger encore
e temps
d'envoyer une capsule SpaceX?
- Marc Garneau, qui était à bord
de la st2000,
condamne les actions de lastatia
à cette crise.
- C'est tellement unique, la
station spatiale i
point de vue symbolique qu'on
voudrait tous que ça demeure
pas contestée,
et où on est capable
de coopérer, de travailler
ensemble.
Ici Normand Grondin,
Radio-Canada, Montréal